Du har skrivit fem minuter, det är då grejerna kommer.
Det är då insikterna kommer, det är då tankarna kommer.
En stor del av vår utveckling har faktiskt tillkommit genom bara att jag sitter och skriver.
För att då börja det som ligger här bakom som inte alltid har tillgång till, det kommer fram.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta, du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi PO på Life Hack Plus till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Välkommen PO.
Tack så jättemycket Johan.
Kan du bara förklara, Life Hack Plus skulle i princip kunna vara vad som helst från ett kosttidskottsvarumärket till hur man sover bättre.
Vad är det för någonting?
Vad ska vi prata om idag?
Vad ska vi snacka om?
Jag tycker det är en ganska bra spaning.
För oss har det hela tiden varit såhär, hur kan vi få ut mer av både oss själva och det vi gör framförallt både professionella men också i vardagen.
Så hela tanken kommer egentligen från att vi vill ha ut mer egentligen.
Det är därifrån namnet kommer också.
Det skulle fortfarande kunna vara ett kosttidskott eller det skulle kunna vara en sömn.
Vad är det ni driver för bolag?
Vi driver ett bolag som verkligen vill hjälpa ledare, entreprenörer, ägare att kunna växa som människor och växa sina team och växa sina bolag utan att på något sätt göra avkall på varken tillväxt eller hälsa i den meningen.
Så för oss har vi ofta sett att utveckling och tillväxt det sker hand i hand hela tiden.
Så vi har valt att angripa det från ett mer bredare perspektiv.
Så kom namnet till och plusset var att vi vill gärna ha lite mer av allt.
Ni är i grunden någon sorts ledarskapsprogram, ledarskapscoaching eller ledarskapsutveckling.
Är det det eller är det mer en livsstilsutveckling?
Hur spesa ni när ni pratar om vad ni säljer in?
Det är en ganska ny take för marknaden, upplever jag, när vi har tittat på hur brukar man annars göra, även om många av våra medgrunder har gått.
Till exempel Tony Robbins utbildningar, där man pratar mycket om business, man pratar om mindset, personlig utveckling.
Och så nämner man ofta hälsa.
Vi har ofta sett att vi vill väva in det där.
Så man kan väl kalla det change management mer åt det hållet.
Men vi väver ju inledarskapen i en superviktig punkt, både det personliga men också hur man leder andra.
Så det blir ju en ganska bred palett av ingredienser.
Typ som när man ska köpa en bil, så kanske man inte alltid tittar på spesen, utan det är mer så här, ja den ska gå fort, den ska vara säker och jag ska tycka om att köra den.
Så för oss så är det mer åt change management och utveckling som vi vill titulera det.
Kärt på honom många namn.
Men om människor ska befinna sig i någon sorts utvecklingsfald, så ett stort bolag som Alfa Laval, de behöver inte gå detta för de ska göra samma sak nästa år också.
Men jag tror att vi har valt att jobba mycket mer, det finns många lösningar, men vi har valt att jobba mycket mer mot entreprenörer och ledare i ofta ägarledda bolag, mindre bolag som är i en tydlig tillväxtfas.
Där tror jag att vi gör absolut mest skillnad.
Sen gör vi avstickare också och kan jättegärna hjälpa större bolag.
Men då behöver man ofta kanske en liten modell för det.
Så hela vår tanke har varit att hjälpa.
Vi ser ofta att det börjar ofta från ledarskapet.
Oavsett om det är den organiskt-
och kulturiska hälsan eller hur det påverkar resultatet i finansiella, så ser vi att det börjar ofta mer med ledarskapet.
Så vi ser ju mer att vi vill jobba med individen bakom, deras utveckling, deras mindset, hur de leder förändring och hur de också ser till att de håller längs hela vägen.
Det blir ju väldigt fokus på en lite mindre bolag och i den tillväxtfasen.
Jag tycker, nu jag hänger ju en del på LinkedIn, och då har ju liksom den hälften som inte heter något med AI, heter ju någonting med coach eller ledarskap i sitt namn.
Så det finns ju rätt mycket människor därute som på något sätt säger att de jobbar med att utveckla ledare eller utveckla ledarskapssituationen eller vad man ska säga.
Vad är det som gör, du säger att ni har en lite bredare, kan du inte beskriva lite vad det är ni gör i bolaget, liksom mer konkret vilka ni är, vad ni kommer ifrån, vad som är liksom er antik på hela den här grejen och varför, alltså rent krasst utan att låta dryg, varför någon ska bry sig om det här i stället är något annat.
Om man älskar det, att man ska bry sig, för det tycker jag faktiskt, vi ser allt mer och mer.
Vi är fyra meter under i det här bolaget.
Min story, alltså min bakgrund, kommer ju med från hälsa och prestation.
Jag har alltid jobbat, vi har ju lite delat bakgrund, du och jag.
Kommer liksom få träningsgolvet så.
Och var väldigt tydligt med målsättningar, jag drev träningsanläggningar och det var liksom resultat, samtidigt som du har mycket kundrelation och coachning.
Jag tror du är gammal i lejk och nisse, visste du så?
Jajamän, visste jag det.
Jag hade med Erik i podden här för tre avsnitt, var han en bra chef eller?
Ja, det är han verkligen.
Det är han verkligen, han är en väldigt fin ledare.
Så det är många kodus till han och hur han agerar som ledare.
Och har gett mig många lärdomar också.
Men du sa ändå upp dig, så att faktor kan vara...
Jag sa ändå upp mig.
Men jag tror att vi kommer till mina drivkrafter snart, så det kommer att finnas en röd tråd i det.
Absolut, absolut.
Vi går tillbaka till styrspelens fråga.
Vi ska inte trakta på konkurrenter.
Som är dels sagt så kommer jag med från hälsaprestationer, så jag har jobbat mycket med elikt och drottare av näringslivet och såg att ofta är hälsa en ganska stark silo man jobbar med.
Det har ofta varit vid sidan om.
En av våra andra medgrundare heter Magnus Helgeson och grundade Harris en gång i tiden och gjorde en jätte resa med det bolaget och numera jobbar vi väldigt mycket med personlig utveckling och ledarskap och så vidare.
Har ju sett hur det funkar.
Sedan har vi en som kommer lite mer från kapitalsidan, jobbat mer mot försäljning och tillväxt.
Fantastisk man som heter Stefan som jag har känt i 15 år.
Sedan har vi en fjärde kille som heter Johan som kommer från branding och har jobbat mycket med.
Han är en av världens största DJs till exempel och har många premiumvarumärken.
Så det är ju personerna bakom.
Så för att komma tillbaka lite till den frågan varför man ska bry sig, och jag tror också att det finns jättemånga kompetenta coacher, utbildare och så vidare.
Och det är jättebra.
Vi har bara valt att se att ofta så behöver man angripa problematiken mer som en helhet, snarare än enskilda delar.
Det var ju så vi rasonerade kring att ofta så har man kanske bara ledarskapet på en bit och så gör man något annat på något annan plats.
Och vi vill samla det på ett koncept, en tydlig resa som i vårt fall löper över tio månader, där det ena steget bygger på grunden, så att man utvecklar sig själv, man utvecklar sitt ledarskap och man bygger sitt välbefinnande som man orkar leda, andra av sig själva.
Så tänk mer att istället för att man gör enskilda insatser så systematiserar vi det genom vårt sätt helt enkelt.
Så 360-systemet skulle man kunna säga för utveckling.
När man kommer in så där, du nämnde nu att det är tio månaders program för det är era basprodukt.
Ja det är vårt flaggskepp brukar jag säga.
Och då har ni ett antal medlemmar som ska gå det här flaggskeppet, visst går de i någon sorts grupp då, gissar jag, eller jag föreställer mig på det.
Är det inte en problematik då att folk, alltså om du sa till exempel hälsa så skulle ju de kunna befinna sig på en människa som tycker det är jobbigt att ställa sig upp i fotöljen och någon som springer med araton för att de tycker det är kul.
Hur får man dem och tycker det är intressant, båda två?
Ja, superbra fråga.
Man kan väl säga som så här att vi gör dels vissa saker i grupp, för vi tror väldigt mycket på accountability, att man lär sig av andra.
För att det är väldigt ensamt att driva bolag, och det är väldigt ensamt att löma vissa frågor.
Så vi tror att det finns en styrka i att man har olika sessioner där man träffas och kan diskutera utmaningar som man stöter på.
Så det finns en aspekt i det.
Men sen när det kommer till hälsoaspekten, den gör man individuellt.
Så oavsett om man kanske kämpar med att jag är extremt trött och bara manglar på hela dagarna.
Till den som tycker att det är superhärligt att dyka upp i triatlontdräkt på jobbet.
Oavsett hur vi kommer att kunna vinkla det individuellt.
Vi gör olika hälsotester för dem också.
För att säkerställa att de håller att de utvecklas.
Men sen gruppsessionerna, där blir det lite andra teman vi går in på.
Hälsa för oss är långt ifrån.
Jag kan ibland uppleva att den branschen du och jag har verkat så länge inom och älskar.
Vi kanske kommer in lite fel ibland när det kommer till att man inte kopplar hälsa till ett resultat.
Utan att det blir kanske något som känns lite flumbo.
Varför ska vi göra det?
Vi har tittat lite på hur vi kan mäta det, hur kan vi utveckla det, hur kan vi bygga förståelse för hur jag stärker mig själv och orkar det vi gör.
Samma fråga inom ledarskap, det kan ju också skilja väldigt mycket.
Det är battrigt så enkelt att dra exemplet inom träning, men vi kan ju ha en person som har tusen anställda och vi kan ha en person som har två anställda och den ena har aldrig avskedat någon och den andra har avskedat 150 pers över femton år.
Hur får man dem att diskutera?
Hur ska de få ut någonting av varandra?
Ja, och i det stora bolaget där så ser jag snarare att vi gör en separat lina för dem.
För de bolagen vi jobbar med främst nu, där är det ofta lite mindre bolag, liksom tio, tjugo anställda som rör sig och bubblar.
Men där handlar det mycket om att både i de sessionerna vi har, till exempel Magnus jobbar med våra ledarskapsfrågor.
Vi gör ju vår bakgrundskoll på alla bolag, så då kan vi också anpassa innehållet så att det matchar den gruppen som går.
Så när vi tar in hemliga gäster på de här vissa sessionerna, eller hemlig gäst med, det låter nästan som någon tv-program men ja, du förstår vad jag menar, så är det också för att matcha lite vilka det är som befinner sig i gruppen.
Fördelen med att vara ganska nya och lite mindre aktörer, det är ju att vi kan vara väldigt agila, vilket jag tycker är det roligaste.
Ni drar igång den första riktiga kullen här om några månader, har ni redan upptäckt att det är det här folk letar efter?
Vad är anledningen till att de vänt sig till er?
Vad är det ni har lyckats nå ut med?
Jag är ju extremt musikintresserad.
Det var en jävligt oväntad mening, det trodde jag inte skulle komma.
Man får ha använt sig till er, jag är musikintresserad.
Då pratar vi om det en stund.
Jag skulle inte ha en liknelse.
Men då sa Jocke Berg, sångaren är känt nämligen i någon dokumentär, att när man sitter och skriver musiken hemma så tänker man inte på att man släpper lösa det, så kommer det vara en massa opinions om det.
När vi satt och designade och ritade det här under våren och hösten, så hade vi en tydlig bild över hur det kommer att se ut.
Men det fina med att vi borde göra en väntelista, så vi hade en hel del intressenter innan vi drog igång.
När vi började prata om det så började folk höra av sig, och då fattade jag att det här blir någonting som man attraheras av.
För de flesta jag har pratat med vill göra något mer än bara växa sitt bolag, man vill också växa sig själv.
Det är de flesta bolagen jag har träffat, där ser man att jag har pratat med en koncernvd här i veckan över lunch och han har 190 anställda.
Men för han var det, jag vill också ta hand om mig själv så att jag åker att driva det här i tio år till till exempel.
Men när vi då släppte det så byggde vi också det ganska publikt.
Så när vi väl började sätta oss med potentiella kunder så vissa ändringar som nu blir i programmet kommer ju från de dialogerna.
Så det vi trodde var att det här är helt rätt.
Det visade sig att vi behövde tweka det på vissa delar.
Och då har vi gjort det.
Och det har varit fördelen också med att vara ganska publika med vad vi konceptualiserar.
Det har varit en jättefördel.
För det är nog kunden som är chef.
Alla vi som är med i bolaget har jobbat med försäljning på många olika sätt.
Jag kan inte se att vi kan göra på något annat sätt att vi behöver anpassa det.
Det vi tror är helt rätt, det måste vi kunna vara öppna för att justera hela tiden.
Vilket vi har gjort då.
Ofta här i podden så hamnar jag i dialoger om e-handel och produktförsäljning för att det är på något sätt de människorna jag ofta känner.
Men det här med att sälja tjänsteutbud, eller personlig utveckling och liknande, det är ju lite knepigare på något sätt att paketera.
Jag tycker det är lite spännande.
Det finns ju många som har försökt sälja tjänster och så är det rätt svårt att liksom sticka ut.
Har ni haft en kundgrupp i tankarna när ni har, du säger ju såhär, entreprenörer absolut, det är ju en ganska bred kundgrupp.
Är det en viss typ ni letar efter, eller har ni paketerat på ett visst sätt för att tilltala den sorten, eller kan du prata lite om hur ni har paketerat detta, eller hur ni når fram till dem ni vill nå fram till?
Jättegärna.
Dels så är ju relationer väldigt viktiga för oss.
Vi har alla haft förmånen att bygga fina relationer, och det är därifrån vi har framförallt sett ett stort intresse.
Det är väl oftast så när man startar någonting, då är det en snätvack först som får upp ögonen för det.
Sen finns det de som är lite i peripherring, som är väldigt nyfikna av följer, men vill kanske se lite vad tar det här vägen.
Men det har varit den stora delen.
Men det vi tidigt definierade var bolag i lite mindre skala, som jag sa innan, fem, kanske tjugo anställda.
Man har kommit upp i lite omsättning, det är runt tio miljoner och över.
Man har antingen en väldigt tydlig entreprenörsanda i bolaget, som en av våra första kunder till var det här programmet som vi ska gå.
Han driver en stor investeringsplattform och de är fem anställda.
Så hade vi ett möte så sa han, men PO, vi går in i det tuffa ståvet någonsin.
För de har vissa investeringar som ska gå in till börsen.
Och svensk som man är så tänker man, då blir det nog inte bra timing liksom.
Då säger han så här, men PO det är därför jag behöver det här nu, för jag måste ha koll på min energi, jag måste ha mindset och jag måste ha med teamet.
Och det var ur kunden för den gruppen vi hade identifierat.
Det vill säga, lite mindre bolag ska göra en resa när man har påbörjat en resa.
Där har vi sett att 35-55-60 år gamla män, kvinnor, starka drivkrafter som värderar både sin egen utveckling, sin hälsa och att göra sitt bolag, att det finns en stark passion där.
Det är en väldigt tydlig målgrupp för oss.
Vi träffar väldigt mycket människor som man vill till något.
Så är det med, man vill gärna utveckla detta, man tycker det är spännande med, hur kan jag tweka de här bitarna för att det ska bli ännu bättre.
Så vi finns inte till för dem som vill, men det är en väldigt tydlig målgrupp för oss.
Jag tänker att den invändning som du på något sätt hade instinktivt där, det är ju den klassiska invändningen.
När vi omsatte 10 miljoner, det var inte så att jag gick runt och tänkte på att jag ska ta tag i min utveckling.
Man känner ju sig inte direkt i den fasen.
Är inte det en rätt krånglig målgrupp att ha?
Är det inte goa att rikta in sig på folk som är lite mer, de har börjat jobba sju timmar om dagen och tycker att deras familj är viktig.
Du vet, hade inte det varit en goa målgrupp.
Jo, men så är det.
Jag tror att man kan ha en träningsreferensen där.
Så är det väl springa fem kilometer eller springa ett ultramaraton liksom i införsäljning.
Vi har de personerna också som såklart har kommit en del på en bit på resan redan då.
Och kanske kommer in lite mer från sitt egna perspektiv snarare än bolagsperspektivet.
Jag satt med en person som kommer från fastighetsbranschen och ska starta ett eget bolag.
För han var det mer viktigt att få koll på om vi gör till exempel en affärsplan på en sida för riktning, tydlighet.
För han var det superviktigt.
Och mer såhär, hur ska jag leda mig själv?
Men för någon annan så var det, jag vill jobba mer med förändringen för processen.
Och eftersom det här programmet, om man tänker det, det täcker väldigt många delar, så det blir också att man kan tweka väldigt mycket utifrån vem det är som är på andra sidan som behöver den hjälpen.
Och skulle man inte behöva det, då får man plocka russinen och kakan och göra andra bra saker med den exaktisen och det synsätt som vi har.
Och som man förhoppningsvis attraheras av.
Men jag håller verkligen med dig.
Kan du inte snacka lite om vad som finns i det här 10-månadersprogrammet som ni pratade om, vad liksom ingår i den, vad konkret gör man?
Vi tar den resan.
Ja men liksom, är det så här, här är två träffar och sen är det fyra digitalkurser och så är det ett, jag avslöjar allt liksom, men vad är det man gör under den här perioden?
Vad snackar man om?
En stor utmaning idag, vi pratar om att det finns ett väldigt fint utbud, och det är fantastiskt.
Jag har alltid en väldigt vänlig inställning till kolleger, får du vilka jag säger, i branschen.
Alla vill ju påverka och göra gott.
Utmaningen som man tittar på, jag läste något forskningsunderlag som såg att ungefär, det råder ingen brist på utbildning idag, men ofta ser man att när man går en utbildning så kanske det blir 10-20% som faktiskt förverkligas av den utbildningen.
Samtidigt så hävdar så här World Economic Forum att man behöver nästan avsätta 4-5 timmar per vecka för lärande, för att det händer så mycket på arbetsmarknaden, både tabartekniken, allt som händer makromässigt.
Så vår idé är ju både kompetensen men att det ska implementeras i vardagen.
Och nu är vi tillbaka lite på träningsspåret, men det tar tid att sätta ett nytt beteende, det tar tid att bygga nästa steg för sig själv.
Så de första perioder där man on-boardas, då tittar vi mer på nuläget.
Vi gör en analys över bolaget, vi gör en analys över hälsan, vi har två workshops där vi tittar på mindset och personlig utveckling.
Vi har en AI workshop, där vi tittar på hur man kan avlasta sig själv för att fria upp ett tid i vardagen, som man bygger sin egen assistent.
Och sen går man mer vidare in i hur jobbar jag med mitt personliga ledarskap, ledarskap i mitt team, hur man bygger sin affärsplan, vi tittar på ledans hälsa.
För att det coola med det är att ledans hälsa har av 200 parametrar, 56 gånger större effekt på den organisatoriska hälsan än andra parametrar.
Och det i sin tur har 18 procent större effekt på slutresultatet på sista raden.
Så för oss är det viktigt att det blir en affär av det.
Det är extremt viktigt att man känner att det finns en affärskritisk del i detta.
Och sen så gör vi såklart uppföljningar.
Vi har de här masterminds där vi träffas i gruppen för att utvecklas.
Men vi tror väldigt mycket på det.
Man har one to one sessions med mig.
Nu får du ju hela programmet här ändå liksom.
Men det finns ju ut det liksom, så det är inte så att vi är rädda att det kopieras.
För oss är det ofta människorna bakom.
Alltså vi är sex stycken i teamet.
Och det är väldigt svårt att kopiera kultur.
Därför är vi väldigt fri costy med hur vi gör.
Vad är det som gör er bättre än något annat sådant här program?
Eller vad är er usp?
Finns det inte andra program med olika människor bakom?
Jo.
Det är okej, du får säga att de andra är skit.
Alltså det är helt okej.
Jag bara menar, vad är det ni är duktiga på?
Det är ju det som är grejen att vi har byggt den plattformen med experter som har erfarenhet.
Alla som vi har, har ju jobbat med det här.
Och det att vi har samvägt det till en, alltså det är lite som att man skulle gå på restaurang istället för att gå på förrättis på ena restaurangen, middagen på tredje år och så där.
Så har vi egentligen byggt ihop det i en resa.
Och det ser jag som vår styrka.
Och mitt jobb är att hålla ihop helheten till den här röda tråden där vi hela tiden tar nästa steg.
För jag tror att, lite som vi var inne på tidigare, att man kanske inte alltid tänker såhär men är det rätt läge?
Men det är ofta väldigt sällan det är rätt läge.
Jag bevusar själv att jag ser upp för mig såhär, ja men det är inte så att ens föräldrar bara är så bra att sälja upp det från ett faste jobb med en stadig lön och hoppa ut i någonting.
Nej, men å andra sidan när är rätt tajming?
Jag tror det är väldigt svårt att hitta rätt tajming och samtidigt så tror jag att när man tar ett steg så blir nästa steg lite tydligare.
Och ibland är man nere i diket och ibland är man hyfsat på rätt väg.
Så för oss är det bara viktigt att vi tar konkreta steg och implementerar det i vardagen.
För det är då vi får effekt, inte att man går en föreläsning med oss.
Det ger väldigt sällan effekt.
Jag är tacksam över att, nu ska inte det här låta som skryt, men jag har fått mejl på LinkedIn åtta år senare att jag lyssnar på dig och jag tänker fortfarande på det här.
Det är väldigt fint när det händer men vi vill verkligen komma in i att det blir en del i vardagen, att det blir vanor man jobbar med.
Och då måste man jobba över längre tid.
Så det är inte så, vi finns inte därför som någon kort inspiration utan det här är snarare någonting man gör och ska finna en känsla av samhörighet kring.
Det känns ju ganska personlighetsbundet.
Har ni gjort någon marknadsföring av detta eller har ni fått in era kunder från att de gillar er?
Ja, det har fått det att man har gillat två take på det här.
Det här är någonting som kanske man inte har artikulerat för sig själv, något som har känt att det här lockas till.
Att det finns en ny approach till det.
Sen är vi ganska tidiga på den svenska marknaden.
Jag tror det hade varit mycket lättare att sälja det här i USA, om man ska vara helt ärlig.
Men den feedbacken vi får är väldigt positiv och det känns väldigt bra.
Sen är jag väl medveten om att det kommer att ta tid som alla nya koncept att sätta.
Men vi har ju fast beslut om att göra det och ha det tålamodet också som krävs.
Men det är ju mycket arbete bakom.
Så främst de kunder som vi har, de kommer primärt från andra uppdrag vi haft tidigare.
Där vi har rätt förtroende i kapital, man har sett att vi är kompetenta och duktiga.
För vi har ju fortfarande varit ganska lite mystiska i vår kommunikation.
Och det har också varit lite medvetet.
Hur finansierar ni detta?
Jag är helt själva.
Jag är tacksam att jag har en ganska teformad kompetens.
Som Johan då, han har styrt upp allting vad brand heter.
Men sen har jag lagt extremt mycket tid på allt ifrån bygga webbsida, allt innehåll.
Programmet har vi byggt under ganska lång tid.
Och haft väldigt mycket hjälp med våra andra fina delägare, med Stefan och Magnus, och brainstormat kring hur vi kan göra.
Allting har vi gjort inhouse.
Vi har inte tagit in en enda krona utifrån, och vi har inte lagt några pengar på marknadsföring eller någonting, utan det har varit hårt arbete, från hjärtat, en del svett och en hel del tårar.
Kan du berätta lite om din bakgrund?
Vi berörde det lite kort, men jag hoppade över det och hoppade in i detta.
Ja men det är helt okej.
Vad har du sysslat med?
Jag har haft förmånen, ibland så...
Har du sett Slamdag Millionär?
Ja.
Inga andra liknande nu, som med musiken där innan, men det är en film om en kille som lyckas vinna den här miljonen genom att han har varit med om en massa olika saker i sitt liv.
Nu har inte jag vunnit miljonen, men jag känner ibland att jag har fått förmånen att göra väldigt många olika saker, från att bli inlurad på ett gym när jag var 18 till att bli platschef där.
Förmånen att jobba är nästan sprintpojket, liksom orkens entreprenörer på den tiden där jag växte upp och fick lära mig ganska tidigt hur man kan jobba med kontakter.
Går du alltid runt och är tacksam?
Du låter som en tacksam människa, fan!
Förlåt.
Har du alltid varit så tacksam i livet?
Nej, det har jag verkligen inte.
Och jag har gjort jättemycket bearbetning av sånt man har varit med om.
Men jag väljer att se det mycket ut, tacksamhet, även när det har gått illa.
Sen är jag inte mer än människa och tycker vissa saker är pyton ibland.
Men överlag ser jag ofta ut en tacksamhetslins.
För jag var på väldigt fel barna när jag var ung, känner jag.
Det kunde gått åt helt fel håll.
Men de personerna som fanns där, de fångade upp något sådant i den här vildesna 18-åringen som jag inte såg.
Det gjorde på något sätt att jag fick en känsla av att tilltro till mig själv.
Att jag kan fixa det här.
Det ledde mig in på träningsvärlden och fick någon platschefsjobb som jag verkligen inte skulle fått.
Jag fick det och det gick ganska bra.
Det ledde mig in att jag blev restaurangansvarig, jag kunde inte ens haka lök.
Men jag hade en vd där som också jobbade mycket med personligt mindset att vi ska framåt.
Det är fokus och det var mycket såhär yes we can.
Eller inget politiskt men det var yes-känsla liksom.
Det tog mig in i företrökshälsovärlden, där jag var mer utvecklade i koncept för det.
Det öppnade också upp massa dödrar mot en väldigt framåtlutade bolag.
Jag som person har alltid jobbat extremt hårt och bevisat mig väldigt mycket.
Det gör såklart att man får mycket tillbaka.
Sen är det klart att man blir lite lurad här och där.
Men det är väl en del av den resan och lärdomen också.
Så min bransch jag har varit i, det är ju det man kallar för hälsovärlden.
Men med de senaste tio åren och bussnisdelen av den, där hälsa blir någonting som är konkurrenskraftigt, snarare så.
Vad är det folkska?
För du pratade förut om att du gjorde lite one to ones och sånt där.
Jag älskar att allting alltid blir på engelska.
Du, du gjorde lite coachansamhet.
En och en.
Och lite masterminds, inte gruppträffar utan masterminds.
Men, för det är så, utan att veta om det, så fick jag den känslan av att du sitter nog och har en sån coachande roll med människor och pratar med ledare om hälsa och sånt där.
Vad är det folk har problem med?
Vad är det vi alla är så jävla dåliga på och borde ta?
Vad är lägst hängande frukt?
Och vad är det folk egentligen borde jobba med som är lite jobbigare?
Vad kan vi göra i första veckan för att känna att vi har gjort något bra?
Och vad borde vi egentligen göra på riktigt för att göra något bra?
Exakt, en sak som vi pratar mycket om, vad kan jag börja med och vad kan jag sluta med?
Det är ofta en sådan del.
De flesta jag har pratat med har sett att man har en väldigt hög leveransnivå.
Man är van vid att pressa sig, man är van vid att köra 110.
Men någonstans där känner de flesta också att det är någonting som egentligen inte funkar.
Så jag pressar och pressar och pressar men det blir inte alltid bättre.
Så det till ord som jag pratar med kombinerade föreläsare eller workshopar, om ni nu tittar på min expertis i hela vårt system, då är det mer att planera sin dag utifrån det som man kan kalla för hjärnans växlar.
Det finns ett begrepp som heter, jag vet att du inte gillar engelska då, men vi kan kalla det engel, vi kan säga hjärnans växlar.
Det är en jätteduktig forskare som har titulerat det för england, men det bygger mer på att man har olika nivåer där man är som skarpast.
Just vid den här tiden där du och jag sitter nu, är min skarpaste period på dagen, så det är jag tacksam för.
Sen har jag en liten dal under tidig eftermiddag, innan jag hämtar mig och kan leverera igen.
Det är någonting som jag märker, för jag jobbar väldigt mycket mot personer som ofta använder hjärnan som främsta arbetsskridskap.
Precis som du, du tänker fram det mesta resultatet ni gör.
Och det tror många som lyssnar på den här podden gör det också.
Så där är ofta en sån här stor vimning i att titta på när är jag som naturligt bäst och hur kan jag lägga mitt viktigaste arbete på den tidpunkten.
Som om jag ska ner och hålla en föreläsning i Malmö nu och sen är ni på ett annat ställe.
Då lägger jag planeringen om det arbetet, det kreativa arbetet på min primetime, vilket är då förmiddagen.
Och sen kanske jag lägger mail och fakturor och admin.
Jag har ju alla hattar i vårt bolag.
Så jag lägger dem enklare uppgifterna eller som inte kräver så mycket kreativitet lägger jag när jag har en tidig eftermiddagsdal.
Och sen kanske har vi möröten på eftermiddagen när jag är lite bättre igen.
Där tror jag man kan vinna supermycket istället för att jobba mot sin kropp och bara grinda hela tiden.
Jag köper det.
Hjälper det?
Finns det något mer?
Jag vill ha mer.
Nej men jag funkar på samma sätt.
Jag är mellan två och tre, jag är fullkomligt meningslös.
Så jag går alltid och springer mellan två och tre för att då har jag fått gjort träningen och så behöver jag inte komma hem och gå iväg och träna sen.
Så kan jag sätta mig och jobba igen på eftermiddagen.
Men sitter jag hemma på helgen mellan två och tre så somnar jag alltid.
Alltså även om jag leker med barnen så somnar jag bara sittandes.
Jag är helt meningslös som människa mellan två och tre.
Då är du ganska stark direkt på morgonen också.
Du är ganska morgonpigg av dig eller?
Ja, jag vaknar, jag sätter mig direkt tre kapitaffor och så är jag igång liksom.
Chopp, chopp, ja.
Och då kan man säga så här, för dem som lyssnar och inte är morgonmänniskor så är det ingen skuldbeläggning utan är man kvällsmänniska.
Jo, dålig är ni som människor.
Det borde skämmas.
För det är lite så här, min, min, min, min, jag var ju tidigare inne på det att vi som tränningsbransch ibland har satt lite käppa hjulet för oss själva med en 5am-club och dena med det fjärde.
Men det är verkligen tillåtet att inte vara bäst på morgonen, är man bättre på efterminnen, då får man bara lägga lyssnin, är jag bättre mellan ett och två, då ska jag göra mitt bästa arbete då.
Så det är ju en väldigt personlig approach i det där.
Och sen en annan sak över lag som jag tror att vi kan bli bättre på, det här är mer för oss själva, men också för team och så, vad är vår syfte, var är vi på väg och hur går det.
När vi har vår teamträffa, då är det det som är tre punkter vi pratar om.
Så vi håller det ganska enkelt hela tiden, vad är fokus för oss.
Måste man gå runt och ha så jävla mycket syfte hela tiden?
Jag tycker folk pratar om att det här är min drivkraft, det här är mitt syfte.
Har folk det, går man runt och tänker på det?
Fan har vi kommit så jävla långt som människor att vi går runt och, jag vet inte om jag går runt och tänker på mitt syfte på dagarna.
Jag jobbar och sen är jag med barnen och sen hänger jag med min fru.
Eller så här, fan gör jag så mycket mer.
Men det är världens finaste syfte.
Men det går ju väldigt bra för dig.
Jo, men jag tycker bara alltid så där när man ska, på något sätt så kan jag tycka att det är lite kontraindikativt.
Det får inte bli högt krav eller?
Nej men om man hela tiden fokuserar så hårt på ett syfte eller så hårt på en grej, så känns det som att kan man lägga så mycket tid och energi på ett fokusområde, eller jag sitter riktigt för att jag är på väg med den här meningen.
Jag känner vad du är på väg och jag fattar hur du tänker.
Jag tror för min del så handlar det mer om vad vi väljer och vad vi väljer bort.
Som en del som dök upp här, det hade vi inte mer från början så att vi skulle involvera AI i vårt arbetssätt.
Nu har vi haft lite webbinarium om AI och så, och det har inte varit för teknikens skull, utan det har ju varit, nu kommer jag tillbaka till det här med syfte då, det har varit för att det kan vara ett sätt att avlasta eller kunna lägga mer tid och friare energi till det som man är duktig på.
Så då är frågan så här, för vår del, som ett ställningstagande, väljer vi att gå den vägen och involvera det, då är det för det här, liksom det tanken, inte för att det är en trend eller liknande.
Så det blir mer för vår del att kunna välja ja eller nej, vad ska vi investera tid och energi i.
Kanske inte att vi ska sätta ett lifehack-flagga på månen om tio år, det är inte det som är det, även om den stora visionen är att skapa attraktiva och lönsamma bolag.
Så det som driver oss idag, det är snarare att göra skillnad med det vi kan påverka.
Men jag förstår att det kan lätt kännas högtravande, att man måste ha ett syfte med allting man gör, eller att det ska kännas så filosofiskt.
Det jag kan tycka är lite riskabelt, eller sådär, är att jag kan uppleva att på något sätt, företagsledare, när man är i uppstarten, de första fem åren, då är man liksom med, man kör, man köper, man tömmer soptunnor, eller man åker ut till kunder, eller man ringer samtal och sånt där.
Och sen kommer man in i någon sorts tankesätt kring, jag måste frigöra min tid, min tid måste bli det viktigaste, jag ska göra det som är viktigast för min hjärna och sånt där.
En ganska stor tid av tiden går ju ut på att göra ganska saker som man inte är bäst på.
Annars använder man ju inte den kapaciteten.
Kan du någonsin känna det med folk att du bara vill säga till dem, slapna av, du måste fortfarande jobba, du måste anstränga dig.
Du får liksom inte bara gå runt.
Nu kanske inte det är ett problem.
Jag bara kan se, fan sorry vilken jävla rant det här blev, men ibland så kan man hänga på kontor.
Vi bygger mycket gym på kontorshotell och då kan man se människor som kanske lite för tidigt köpte ett lite för dyrt kontor som de hänger på för att de vill kunna tänka i fred och det är viktigt att de gör strategiarbete.
Vafan ni är tre pers, ni behöver göra nån strategi, ni ska bara sälja till.
Det är inte så jävla svårt.
Nej men det är lätt då, så jag köper det liksom.
Och vi har inget av denna osäkerhet, vi har inte nåt kontor så.
Nu bor ju vi väldigt utspritt ska jag också säga.
Men vi har gjort allt för att liksom växa den här kostymen på vad vi tycker är klokt sett och var väldigt öd med Rukin för den resan.
För att det är klart, det är superhärligt med strategier och idéer och planer.
Men det är det som bygger karaktär, det är ju det man gör varje dag.
Alltså det går liksom inte att inte lyfta luren eller lägga de där obekväma meddelandena som man bara tänker gud hoppas de inte ser det här eller liknande.
Och jag gjorde det för några veckor sedan, jag skickade det till en person som jag har så otrolig respekt för.
Så här tänkte jag att jag måste bara chankvissa.
Och så bara dyker han upp på min föreläsning och så vill han att jag ska föreläsa på hans bolag.
Och det är så här, det kommer inte gratis.
Jag säger inte att jag är bäst på något sätt utan bara så här, men det är ändå de här små grejerna som ingen ser som man gör när man inte känner att livet är toppen.
Det är ändå det som man måste göra varje dag.
Jag träffar ju många bolag som har jättefina tavlor med värdeord och det är en jätteklassiker, att nu har vi bestämt att vi ska vara modiga eller vänliga.
Men kommer man då till receptionen och får ett kildt hej, kulturen är ju det vi gör varje dag.
Du sa att jag kände mig som en tacksam person, så ja men vi har tillit, relationer, ödmjukhet, räll.
Det är viktiga saker för oss i vårt team, men det är ju ingenting som, det ser snyggt ut, men det är ju hur vi bemöter människor i allt vi gör som spelar roll.
Det är ju på den sättet man bygger kulturen.
Nu kanske du behöver en lång utlängning från min sida.
Nej men kör på, det är bara ärligt.
Det är det som är det.
Jag har nog alltid varit en liten intrapreneur, vilket har gjort att jag har sköts upp mig som du var inne på tidigare.
Jag har inte stök på något sätt, men jag har nog alltid velat lite mer.
Jag har velat utveckla, justera och driva saker.
Det funkar ju till en viss nivå.
Sedan har jag nog känt att jag skulle vilja bygga någonting med människor som de vill åt samma håll.
Det har väl gjort att jag tatt den här risken, får man säga, eller möjligheten.
Även om jag har varit jätteriskt benägen och god vågar verkligen detta.
Men därifrån kommer det och då är det att göra det här som ingen annonserat.
Det vet ju alla som på något sätt har byggt ett bolag också.
För jag tror att för min del så har den här kanske lite naiviteten som jag har varit en jättehjälp, för annars hade jag ju inte gjort det här.
För det är ju mycket mer än vad någonsin kan tro att bygga ett bolag.
Det tror jag alla kan skriva under på som gör det eller har gjort det.
Jag vet inte hur du känner men det är ju liksom det är ju extremt tufft och du är ju väldigt duktig på att skriva om det.
Men då tror jag att det är lätt att glorifiera det kanske i sociala medier och så.
Men man ser inte kanske allt tufft slit bakom.
Så det är verkligen inget som, och det är väl en del av det som vi vill trycka på också, att det inte faller.
Det är därför vi gör det över lång tid för att det tar tid att bygga.
Bra, vi fick båda leva ut från monologerna.
Men jag tyckte det var bra.
Jag ska försöka hitta tillbaka till någon sorts röd tråda.
Jag gillar det här avsnittet för vi rör oss i, jag har ingen aning om var vi hamnar, men jag känner att vi får in många ämnen i alla fall, så det är alldeles utmärkt.
Ja men jag älskar det också.
Men jag tycker det är härligt för jag tycker ibland att det är lätt att tro såhär att, bara för någon hammare så är allt en spik.
Exakt.
Och det är det ju inte.
Och jag tror ibland man behöver bara ta ett steg tillbaka och se att vi behöver många delar för att det ska funka liksom.
Och då blir ju jag glad att vi har det teamet vi har.
För det är alltid någon man kan vårdfråga.
Det är alltid någon som har en idé och så vidare.
Så jag tror också att det är viktigt.
Snarare än att bara bygga strategier hela dagarna, planer, att man har människor som liksom är disciplinerade och gör det man säger man ska göra.
Det är vimni och så.
Det är en culture, vad är det man säger?
Du ska ju inte ta någon sånna flåskor.
Culture beats strategy and blah blah blah beats every day for lunch.
Det är någon sån där mening exakt.
Ja exakt och det är ju en flåskor på ett sätt, men det är ju bara hårt arbete som spelar roll.
Ingenting kommer gratis.
Jag brukar aldrig dra av life hacks och sånt, men är det okej att vi fastnar lite i det?
För det känns som att du har lite sådana grejer.
Och jag tänker eftersom du har föreläst en del och sånt där, då har man dessutom behövt tänka på det, man har behövt fastna.
Du nämnde ju här innan med planera livet ut efter lite tider och sånt där när man är mest produktiv.
Har du några fler sådana där, jag kallar det för hacks men liksom, jag använder också engelska, men har du några fler sådana där saker som verkligen, fan det här har verkligen funkat för mig i livet, det här har gjort stor skillnad.
Ja, absolut.
Jag har två delar som jag tänker på, så här top of mind, som jag tror många kan känna igen sig i.
För jag har alltid varit en sökare eller nyfiken, och väldigt early adopter på det mesta, när det kommer till både hälsa och teknik.
Vilket verkar vara jättekul att prova liksom, men man har också lärt sig såhär, dyköpta lärdomar.
Så det är två delar som jag tänker på.
Den ena delen, för jag satt för en tid sen med en jätteduktig vd på ett bolag, ett managementbolag i Stockholm, och han pratade om en reflektionstid.
Det är något som man sällan avsätter tid till, men vi premierar alltid outputen.
Outputen är det viktigaste, men vi lägger mycket fokus på tiden vi lägger på det.
Så det första delen som jag tänker på när du tar upp den Joel, det är att använda papper och penna för att reflektera.
Det låter banalt, men det har varit en game changer för mig.
Att verkligen skriva ner tankar, idéer, och liksom bara rita ner det på papper.
För det finns en stark koppling där.
Och det tror jag är rätt att glömma idag.
Det där har man ju hört många gånger, att folk har sagt, men det är lite som meditation, det har ju också många sagt, att det har verkligen funkat för mig.
Men när du säger det här, reflektera, vad rent krass är det du reflekterar över?
Hur gör du för att få det?
Vad är det det ger dig?
För jag kan inte riktigt förstå, jag vill förstå vad det ger dig.
Ja, och jag vet själv en gång, jag mediterade över 300 dagar i streck, och sen skrev jag en artikel om vad jag hade lärt mig.
Och jag har även varit på meditationsproffet och så.
Det är skönt men det ger inte mig så mycket som person.
Och det är inte rätt för alla.
Vissa mår mycket bättre av att gå ut och springa, till exempel.
Så det är så här, whatever floats your boat, om jag nu ska ta de engelska grejerna igen.
Nej, så det jag gör egentligen, det är två delar.
Antingen så har jag förutbestämda frågor.
Så för mig varje söndag så tittar jag på vad jag har gjort, vad har jag lärt mig eller vilka att mönsterisera, vad ska jag börja med att sluta med och vad är viktigt nästa vecka.
Så i söndags då, då var en av punkterna att prata med Joel, det var viktigt för mig.
Och så hade jag sex andra punkter, men du var topp ett.
Och det gör att man börjar se, om jag två veckor av skriver, jag ser att jag skjuter på att ringa ett kunstsamtal, då blir det väldigt tydligt att det är det jag börjar fokusera på, så jag har ett ramverk som jag jobbar med.
Det andra delen är faktiskt att bara skriva, det kallas för flow journaling, man bara skriver.
Det kan för första gången man testar det, verka helt märkligt.
Då kanske man skriver, jag vet inte vad jag ska skriva, men jag skriver ändå, för hjärnan tänker.
Men nu har du kommit förbi den, du har skrivit till fem minuter, det är då grejerna kommer, det är då insikterna kommer, det är då tankarna kommer.
En stor del av vår utveckling har faktiskt tillkommit genom att jag sitter och skriver, för att börja det som ligger här bakom, de som inte alltid har tillgång till det kommer fram.
Just det, det här märkte jag en gång.
Så det är bara att man tömmer hjärnan på information.
Det har varit för mig väldigt frigörande.
Så det kan vara som två konkreta verktyg.
Antingen har jag ett tydligt barnverk.
Kunde du börja med det direkt eller behövde du lära dig det?
Jag bara tänker att det är också en egenskap som vissa människor kanske har och vissa har verkligen lätt för.
Nej men jag hade inte det, jag hade inte det.
Första gången jag skulle göra det, det kändes så konstigt.
Vad håller jag på med PO?
Vem är du?
Vad är detta?
Sluta nu.
Det är de tankarna som vi alla får.
Men när man har gjort det några dagar, så är det okej, nu börjar det dyka upp grejer här.
Det är inte konstigt att första gången du kommer till gymnasiet och går på en steppmaskin, du ramlar av den för du har inte balans.
Men efter några gånger så är det okej, nu har jag flow.
Det var precis samma.
Jag tror att vad man än gör i livet, så är de första tillfällena lite skakiga, oavsett vad man ska göra.
Men det är ju bara fortsätta.
Så jag fattar att man känner, vad är det han pratar om?
Men prova, det kan nånting bli sämre, värre eller sämre förbli som det är eller bättre.
Troligtvis blir det bättre för att börja frigöra den potential som du har.
I den AI-världen vi lever i idag, där allting kan kopieras, allting kan produceras, då är människan bakom ännu viktigare.
Så det öppnar bara upp mer av dig och blir en konkurrensfördel.
Det andra ramverket, vad har jag gjort?
Vad har gått bra?
Vad ska jag sluta med att börja med?
Vilka mönster ser jag?
Vad är viktigt?
Det är också en tydligare vad jag ska lägga min tid på, och kanske vad jag ska sluta göra.
Jag är ju naturligt en ja-sägare.
Det är ju ofta bra, men det har ju ställt till det också.
Men det är sånt som man märker när man ser ett mönster.
Jag tänker att alla vi som har jobbat inom träning, för man kan ju frågasätta varför kan man inte bara sitta och tänka, måste man skriva ner allting, men alla som har jobbat som någon sorts tränare eller coach vet ju på något sätt hur mycket kraftfullare det blir när man skriver ner det, även om man inte visar någon så är det liksom extremt signifikant, mycket bättre att skriva ner det.
Ja men gud ja, det finns ju en sån här Harvard-studie som hade följt människor med mål och ditten och datten.
Så det är inte rätt för alla men om det känns rätt prova, för min övertygelse är att man kommer att känna både lättare i sinnet och det blir lite klarare och tydligare.
Så det är de två delarna.
Sen den andra delen då, eller det blev en del som blev två, sen har vi en annan grej som jag också tänker på, och nu blir det nästan en föreläsning här men jag tänker att jag...
Ja, det var trevligt.
Ja, men det andra är, jag sa det innan, att det är väldigt lätt i vår värld att man tror att alla måste gå upp tidigt och så.
Tyvärr la jag ganska mycket tid på det där när jag var yngre, för det var något jag hade fått för mig, och shit, jag måste också göra det.
Men det som jag har märkt, kanske den största skillnaden för många som jag jobbar med, har ju snarare gjort hur man stänger av dagen innan.
För då blir det per automation eller definition lättare dagen efter.
Det finns en jättestark koppling mellan god sömn, kreativitet, problemlösning och stresshantering.
Har du vaken i 18 timmar så är du ungefär som att köra nästan rattfull, alltså 0,5 på mille.
Det har varit mer fokus på att varva ner och se till att du somnar gott, för det underlättar allt du ska göra dagen efter, oavsett om du är en morgonmänniska eller en kvällsmänniska.
Så det är väl mer att titta snarare på det ibland, för det borgar, då gör det att allting nästa dag blir mycket lättare.
Och när man tittar på ledarskap och så, det är rätt svårt att vara en bra ledare om man är trött och angry.
Så det är en del som har vuxit fram väldigt mycket de senaste åren i det arbetet man gör.
Känner du att det hjälper lite?
Ja, jag gillar när man vänder på perspektiv på det sättet.
För jag tror att många gör på just det sättet, att de tänker att jag ska vakna klockan fyra, jag ska gå upp och så ska jag ta en kall dusch som alla hatar, och sen ska jag träna en timme och sen måste jag äta, fira skåla i Blåberg, absolut.
Men börja med att gå och lägga dig i tid och inte spela dataspel sista halvtimmen typ.
Alltså, du kan ju börja där, så ser vi vart du hamnar typ.
Ja men jag håller med och jag känner de som gör, det är ovannämnda protokoll om att känna att det är toppen.
Så har jag de som tycker tvärtom.
Och båda de här är väldigt duktiga på det de gör.
Så det kommer ju bara tillbaka till att man leder sig själv på ett klokt sätt.
Jag fann en jävla spännande avsnitt.
Kul att få lite olika input åt alla möjliga håll.
Jag hoppas folk har fått med sig någonting från antingen hur jävla knepigt det är att starta ett tjänstebolag.
Dels att man ska gå utanför sin comfort zone lite, dels lite olika hacks och dels lite, nästan som en mini föreläsning i poddformat.
Stort tack för att du var med PO, det var väldigt intressant.
Det var nog mitt mest unika avsnitt känner jag.
Va?
Okej, coolt.
Det är så vi jobbar.
Ja, exakt.
Lycka till med programmet i framtiden.
Tack snälla.
Sitter jag hemma på helgen mellan två och tre så somnar jag alltid.
Även om jag leker med barnen så somnar jag bara sittandes.
Jag är helt meningslös som människa mellan två och tre.